[Musik]
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
Donnerstagabend 22 Uhr 13 Sie sind im
zweiten deutschen Fernsehen und das ist
gut so seit heute hat Deutschland einen
neuen Verteidigungsminister in dieser
Zeit das wichtigste Amt neben dem
Kanzler Mainz die CDU Boris Pistorius
soll es besser machen und viele sagen
das dürfte nicht so schwer werden aber
damit ist noch längst nicht alles gut
weder für die Soldaten noch für die
Steuerzahler und vor allem nicht für die
Ukraine die soll bekommen was bei der
Bundeswehr noch funktioniert viel ist
das nicht und würde wenn das diesen
Krieg entscheiden wir müssen reden mit
diesen Gästen
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert
seraphyla CDU verteidigungspolitikerin
Anna Sauerbrei von der Zeit
Politikwissenschaftler Carlo Masala
Thomas kleine Brockhoff German Marshall
Fund
und vom Bundeswehrverband andre Wüstner
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt alle Gäste dieser
Sendung noch mal ausgesprochen herzlich
los geht es mit einer nicht ganz
unwichtigen Personalie ist es nur eine
oder ist es der Versuch politisch noch
mal neu zu starten
die Wege des Herrn sind unergründlich
bereits am dritten Januar schmeißt seine
ganz ganz bedeutende
Verteidigungsministerin intern Krieg in
Europa desolate Bundeswehr der Kanzler
muss durchstarten aber dalli dalli das
ist jetzt das neue deutschlandtempo es
folgen 13 Tage Gewichten von Personen
und schwupps bestätigt der neue am
Dienstag den Anruf gestern geht doch für
den Kaltstart mit
US-Verteidigungsminister Austin heute
und Rammstein morgen ist Pistorius
bestens gerüstet ich lese seit gestern
nichts anderes mehr
[Musik]
stolz wie Bolle ist auch der Kanzler auf
seinen überraschungs-kuh jemand der über
sehr sehr viele Erfahrungen in der
Sicherheitspolitik verfügt ein
erstklassiger Verteidigungsminister also
noch einer
Zitat Scholz die Bundeswehr hat eine
erstklassige Verteidigungsministerin
Kevin Kühnert ist bei uns der SPD
Generalsekretär wird Boris Pistorius
auch ein ganz ganz bedeutender neuer
Minister sein
also ich habe heute die ersten
Statements von ihm gehört und ich bin
sehr froh dass er jetzt der
Verteidigungsminister ist Hans Rosenthal
hat glaube ich recht das ist spitze dass
er dieser Aufgabe jetzt übernimmt und
wir wollen ihn dabei unterstützen dass
er ein sehr guter Minister sein kann
jetzt muss man natürlich dazu sagen die
Hoffnung ist dass er ein sehr guter
Minister sein kann ohne sich noch die
ganzen nächsten zweieinhalb Jahre
permanent mit einem Krieg beschäftigen
zu müssen also ich hoffe er kann sich
beweisen ohne dass in einem Zustand
eines Krieges und unserer Nachbarschaft
andauern tun zu müssen ich kenne keinen
der sich das nicht wünschen würde und
trotzdem ist die Situation eine andere
bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dieser
Wahl bei dieser ministerwahl seit 3
Januar hat der Spiegel recherchiert
wusste er spätestens von der Dimension
von Frau Lamprecht hat er so lange
gesucht oder hat er so lange nicht
gefunden
bis gestern müssten sie ihn selber
fragen
also nur weil der Spiegel das schreibt
sind die Abläufe ja nicht tatsächlich so
der Bundeskanzler macht sich natürlich
seine Gedanken über die Dinge dafür muss
er nicht immer zum Telefon greifen
sondern das kann man auch so machen und
die Qualität der Entscheidung jetzt am
Ende spricht ja dafür dass er nicht
hilflos waren seine Entscheidung sondern
dass eine gute Idee gehabt hat und
derjenige der diese Idee war der sollte
jetzt die Chance haben seinen Job
ordentlich antreten zu können
Landesverbände sind zu berücksichtigen
auch Verhältnisse in Bezug auf
Parteiflügel das Geschlecht ist zu
berücksichtigen und herauskamenbares
pistorium
vor allem sollte es ein guter Minister
sein der dieser Aufgabe jetzt an der
Stelle gewachsen ist dass wir jetzt
keine Parität mehr im Kabinett haben da
haben sie jetzt indirekt darauf
hingedeutet tut uns weh um das deutlich
anzusprechen es bleibt auch das Ziel der
Sozialdemokratie das Parität zwischen
den Geschlechtern in
Entscheidungspositionen hergestellt
werden kann jetzt ging es um eine
einzelne Entscheidung es ist der
ausgewählt worden der jetzt verfügbar
war und am besten in dieses Profil
gepasst hat das ist Boris Pistorius und
der wird einen guten Job machen sagt ein
offensichtlich erleichterter
Generalsekretär Frau Sauerbrei in der
Zeit zuständig für Außenpolitik würden
sie wie Herr Kubicki von der FDP sagen
dass es nicht die letzte Chance sondern
die letzte
Munition war die ich Holz jetzt ziehen
kann und muss um diese zeitenwände die
angekündigte tatsächlich glaubwürdig
noch umzusetzen
ja ich glaube die Zeit drängt vor allen
Dingen drängt sie für die Ukraine und
damit letztlich auch für die Länder die
die Ukraine unterstützen also auch
Deutschland und ein Jahr ist jetzt von
dieser Legislaturperiode schon ins Land
gegangen ohne dass die wesentlichen
Punkte angefasst worden also
Neuorganisation im
Verteidigungsministerium selbst
Neuorganisation der Bundeswehr auch das
Geld wird man vielleicht noch mal
anschauen müssen es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht reichen also da ist einiges zu tun
und sollte am besten jetzt sofort
loslegen und glauben sie dass damit auch
ein Neustart verbunden ist aus der Sicht
des Bundeskanzlers weil er auch
empfindet dass diese letzten 11 Monate
nicht besonders instruktiv werden das
hätte man auch schon früher sehen können
also er hätte ja auch viel früher
handeln können jetzt nicht nur seit die
Verteidigungsministerin Ministerin im
Januar ihren Rücktritt angeboten hat
sondern auch schon im vergangenen Jahr
als deutlich wurde dass sie nicht
schnell genug mit dieser Aufgabe
vorwärts kommt also es ist sicherlich
ein Neustart in diesem Ministerium ich
glaube für die ganze Ernährung nicht für
die ganze Bundesregierung nicht bei uns
ist sehr kühler in einer neuen Funktion
nämlich als verteidigungspolitikerin der
CDU Frau Güter würden Sie sagen
zwei drangig aber auf dem Weg
erstklassig zu werden wie fällt ihre
Beurteilung aus in Bezug aufhören
historius ich würde ihn jetzt nicht als
beitrangig bezeichnen definitiv nicht da
bin gute Voraussetzungen mit er hat zehn
Jahre sehr erfolgreich an
Innenministerium geleitet der ist
parteiübergreifend sehr anerkannt das
sind gute Voraussetzungen er ist in der
Sicherheitspolitik sehr gut bewandert
hat auch früh Akzente gesetzt die jetzt
glaube ich auch für den
Bundesverteidigungsminister sehr wichtig
sein werden zum Beispiel das Thema
cybersicherheit da hat er ganz früher
einen Ansatz gehabt und insofern bringt
der gute Voraussetzungen mit und an
dieser Stelle passt es eigentlich nur
ihm viel Erfolg dabei zu wünschen eine
glückliche Hand und wir werden ihn als
Opposition bei dieser Aufgabe auch
konstruktiv sicherlich auch kritisch
begleiten und dann kann man hier
definitiv nicht von zweiter Wahl
sprechen ich hätte mir natürlich
gewünscht dass es eine Frau ist aber
darauf kommt es glaube ich am Ende nicht
an ist dahinter lässt nur einen kleinen
Beigeschmack
so nach dem Motto wenn es hart auf hart
kommt kann es eigentlich nur ein Mann
machen ist aber eher ein Thema wo was
mit der SPD glaube ich nach Hause geht
aber noch mal er verdient absolute
Unterstützung natürlich auch von uns und
ich hoffe er wird das gut machen ein
fairer erster Gedanke Thomas kleine
Brockhoff ist bei uns vom German
Marshall fun das ist ein
deutsch-amerikanischer Sänger Denkfabrik
darf man auch sagen sie sind Publizist
dazu und kennen sich in diesem
deutsch-amerikanischen Verhältnis sehr
gut aus Christine Lambrecht war die auf
dieser internationalen Bühne um die
Frage auch noch mal zu stellen war sie
auf dieser großen internationalen Bühne
tatsächlich für diesen Bundeskanzler
eine ampelregierung eine gute wichtige
Übersetzerin deutscher verteidigungs-
und Außenpolitik
größeren ist vielleicht ein gutes Wort
weil sie ja weil ja viele Entscheidungen
im Kanzleramt getroffen worden sind
insofern war sie auch eine implementärin
in des Kanzleramtes aber natürlich ist
sie auch internationaler Ebene in der
Situation reingekommen worden von der
wir als Gesellschaft
ist sie reingekommen in die mit der wir
ja alle so ein bisschen in eine
kaltdusche gekriegt haben insofern würde
ich sagen den Kaltstart den den musste
Frau Lambrecht absolvieren und in
gewissen Sinne gerne hier Pistorius der
konnte sich wie wir alle ganze
Gesellschaft auf diese Situation
einstellen Frau Lamprecht hatte diesen
Vorzug nicht und ich glaube wir sehen
erst jetzt die größte die Dramatik der
Veränderungen und der Reform
hat eben ein paar angefangen deswegen
beim Geld angeht über die Ausrüstung
weiter geht über das Beschaffungswesen
weiter werden nur darüber
Rüstungsexporte wir werden uns über
Industriepolitik unterhalten müssen im
Grunde kommen wir an in einem Zeitalter
das wir uns haben erzählen lassen
nämlich einem der Abschreckung und der
Aufrüstung naja von Aufrüstung will ich
mal nicht reden wir haben abgerüstet von
500.000 auf 180.000 niemand in diesem
Land schlecht vor von 180.000 500.000 zu
gehen sondern das was gemacht werden
soll ist die kleine Truppe die wir haben
modern
einsatzbereit und abschreckungsfähig so
zu halten das ist die Aufgabe und daher
wünsche ich mir bisschen sie haben es
eben in dem Vorspann gehabt Deutschland
Tempo wir sind ja hingegangen in diesem
letzten Jahr und haben
eine eine Gaspipeline bauen können und
ein gasthörnern bauen können in
Deutschland aber wir haben es mit der
mit der mit der Verteidigung nicht so
eilig gehabt und da muss man meine
aufnehmen genau auch darüber wenn wir
heute reden Carlo Marsala ist bei uns
Politik Wissenschaftler Politologe
militär-experte bekannt natürlich aus
Funk und Fernsehen auch noch mal eine
Frage die sie sowieso nicht falsch
verstehen man muss noch mal erklären ob
eigentlich Menschen für ein solches
spezielles Amt auch geeignet sind selbst
wenn sie nicht Experten sind also selbst
wenn sie nicht Militär sind und jetzt
als Verteidigungsminister in eine so
diffizile nationale als auch
internationale Lage kommen ist das
schlecht wenn man nicht Experte ist und
dennoch einer solchen Aufgabe
gegenüberstellen nein ich finde also
zunächst einmal widerspricht es im
Prinzip unserer parlamentarischen
Demokratie ich glaube die einzige
Tradition die die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat ist das ein
Justizminister immer volljährig ist
ansonsten ein Familienminister muss
nicht Vater oder Mutter
seinen Gesundheitsminister muss nicht
Arzt oder schwer krank sein also das
entspricht einfach nicht der Tradition
deswegen kann jeder im Prinzip der
gewählt ist oder jeder der Politiker ist
vom Bundeskanzler zu einem Minister
gemacht werden ich glaube die
Voraussetzungen die man braucht ist a
die Bereitschaft sich wirklich schnell
tief und umfassend einzuarbeiten in das
Thema und das hat Frau Lamprecht nicht
gemacht ich war ja nicht im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium aber ich
sag mal so sie haben an dem Interview
heute im heute schon mal und ich glaube
beim ard-brennpunkt gesehen dass der
Pistorius obwohl er jetzt irgendwie seit
zwei Tagen erst weiß dass er
Verteidigungsminister ist zumindest das
Vokabular schon sehr gut beherrscht und
den Eindruck erweckt er hat eine Ahnung
von dem was er da sagt also die
Bereitschaft sich einzuarbeiten bei der
beim Verteidigungsministerium ist
natürlich auch extrem wichtig anders als
bei anderen Ministerien die Bereitschaft
sich mit denen auseinanderzusetzen die
für einen arbeiten und damit meine ich
nicht das BMVg sondern ich meine die
Truppe also diese 180.000 Soldaten und
Soldatinnen und die ich weiß nicht
40.000 Zivil Angestellten das wird seine
Aufgabe sein auch in die Truppe zu gehen
sich vorzustellen sich anzuhören was
sozusagen Soldaten und Soldatinnen
wollen machen tun wenn man das macht hat
schon gute Voraussetzungen und wenn man
gleichzeitig gute Berater und
Beraterinnen um sich hat gute
Voraussetzungen einen durchaus
erfolgreichen Job zu machen und
durchsetzungsfähig scheint dazu sein
wenn man seine Zeit in Niedersachsen
sieht als Innenminister da hat er wohl
ein durchaus problematisches Ministerium
übernommen das hat er sehr schnell
sozusagen von rechts auf links gedreht
er hat die flüchtlingskrise glaube ich
ganz gut gemanagt und auseinander
Perspektive das heißt ich glaube schon
dass er die Voraussetzungen mitbringt
aber mein Punkt ist halt die Person an
der Spitze ist nur ein Teil also es
braucht eines breiteren Teams sozusagen
dass diese Aufgabe angeht weil es ist
halt sozusagen schon ein Riesenapparat
und ein sehr komplizierter Apparat
dieses Problem
eigentlich ohne regierbar ist weil so
viele verschiedene Interessen
zusammenkommen das ist schon angeklungen
in der Äußerung von Herrn kleine
Brockhoff eben Industrie und auf der
anderen Seite eben viele verschiedene
Bundeswehr als solches inklusive der
Regierungsarbeit aber noch mal eine
Frage zu Frau Lamprecht Frau Sauerei im
Grunde möchte man hier auch verstehen
warum Olaf Scholz sie so lange gehalten
hat war Christine Lambrecht auch
nützlich für diesen Bundeskanzler weil
sie auf der einen Seite natürlich
Blitzableiter war und auf der anderen
Seite ihn eben in den entscheidenden
Dingen hat gewähren lassen ich glaube da
spielen zwei Punkte eine Rolle das eine
ist glaube ich das sehr stark auf sie
geguckt wurde und ich habe darüber wurde
manchmal vergessen dass ein paar der
Dinge sie auch gar nicht lösen konnte
weil es eigentlich strategische Fragen
sind die das Bundeskanzleramt am Ende
beantworten muss also mir ist immer noch
nicht klar was ist eigentlich das Ziel
das Interesse Deutschlands in diesem
Krieg es gibt eine ganze Menge Floskeln
die ohne Ende wiederholt werden die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren die Ukraine
muss diesen Krieg gewinnen aber was
heißt das eigentlich für uns heißt dass
das wirklich deutschland und die anderen
Verbündeten die Ukraine unterstützen
Russland aus dem Land ganz
herauszudrängen heißt das dass man die
unter Ukraine nur so weit unterstützt
dass sie das eine neue kontaktlinie
entsteht nach einem Friedensschluss und
daran mischt sich auch was die
Bundeswehr liefert was sie am Schluss
beschaffen muss was der
Verteidigungsminister die
Verteidigungsministerin organisieren
muss und dadurch dass die Kritik auf sie
ging hat man darüber immer vergessen
Scholz diese Frage eindringlich genug zu
stellen genau ich glaube das ist der der
wichtigste Punkt und der andere ist
natürlich seine persönliche Bockigkeit
sich von niemanden in nichts treiben
lassen zu wollen aber ich glaube auch
darin hat er sich letztlich unbeweglich
gemacht also er hat sich zum Prinzip
gemacht nicht das zu tun was Experten
sagen was Leitartikel sagen was er im
Prinzip auch gut ist also wir wollen ja
auch kein Kanzler der über jeden Stock
springt aber jetzt ist er so eingemauert
gewesen
dass er dann sie bis zum letzten Tag
noch Bier trinken gegangen ist und noch
eine lng-plattform eröffnet hat bisher
dann eine Entscheidung getroffen hat und
ich glaube auch das ist so ein Faktor
warum er so lange an ihr festgehalten
hat naja und damit letztendlich auch dem
neuen Verteidigungsminister ein Personen
Dienst erwiesen hat meine wenn es
tatsächlich zutrifft das Landrecht am 3
Januar ihren Rücktritt angekündigt hat
dann hätte dieser Rücktritt doch letzte
Woche schon passieren können Boris
Pistorius hätte schon letzte Woche
ernannt werden können und hätte für
heute bei dem Treffen bei dem Treffen
mit dem USA Verteidigungsminister auch
für morgen in Sandstein einfach noch mal
eine ganz andere vorarbeitungszeit
gehabt und insofern geht das natürlich
schon mit Scholz nach Hause dass er das
so ja schleifen lassen hat nicht ernst
genug genommen hat oder dachte sie wird
am Ende doch nicht zurücktreten ich weiß
nicht was ihm durch den Kopf gegangen
ist aber damit hat er definitiv dem
neuen Verteidigungsminister erstmal ein
Bärendienst erwiesen der ja vor großen
Herausforderungen steht ich hatte heute
das Gefühl bei seinem Statement das ist
ihm alles sehr sehr bewusst der ist auch
mit sehr viel Demut und Respekt heute
zusammengegangen einiges wurde ja schon
genannt aber ich glaube gerade für
morgen ist auch wichtig eine der größten
Herausforderungen dass wir bei unseren
internationalen Verbündeten auch wieder
als zuverlässiger und vertrauensvoller
Partner gelten müssen das muss wieder
hergestellt werden lassen ist Hermann
und dann wollen wir ganz kurz mal Herrn
Kühnert auch drei setzen drei
ich will das jetzt mal überspitzt
formulieren bewusst aber wenn unter
diesem Verteidigungsminister in den
nächsten drei Jahren die ihm noch
bleiben nicht die entscheidenden Weichen
gestellt werden dann sieht es sozusagen
für die Einsatzfähigkeit Wehrhaftigkeit
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr für
den Rest sozusagen der nächsten Dekade
sehr sehr schlecht aus das heißt er muss
jetzt wirklich sozusagen das ganze die
Flagge einrahmen nach denen die sich die
Bundeswehr das Verteidigungsministerium
das ganze System sozusagen mit
Rüstungsindustrie und alles in den
nächsten Jahren unabhängig davon wer die
Wahl dann danach noch mal gewinnen wird
wenn neue Verteidigungsminister werden
wird oder Verteidigungsministerin das
muss er jetzt Einnahmen wenn diese
Chance verpasst wird dann sieht es sehr
bitter für die Bundeswehr sozusagen ab
der nächsten Legislaturperiode gibt es
keine 100 Milliarden mehr die sind dann
ausgegeben ja dann gibt es einen
Einzelplan 50 der irgendwo vielleicht
bei 50 Milliarden sein wird das wird all
das nicht decken was sozusagen dann da
ist also Truppenstärke das neue Gerät
ähm Hügel hat ja schon 200 Milliarden
noch dazu verlassen das halte ich für
total unrealistisch jetzt noch mal 200
Milliarden sozusagen draufzupacken ich
halte es für viel wichtiger dass jetzt
sozusagen die Parteien im Deutschen
Bundestag anfangen zu diskutieren
inwieweit er Einzelplan 14 also der
verteidigungszeit dauerhaft erhöht
werden muss um die Zeit nachdem das
Sondervermögen nicht mehr zur Verfügung
steht um sozusagen dieses Delta zwischen
dem was es kostet und dem was an Geld da
ist was ohnehin groß ist zu verringern
wir sind jetzt schon mitten in den
Problemen in den nationalen Problemen
des zukünftigen verteidigendes
Verteidigungsministers mit der
Bundeswehr aber bleiben vielleicht ganz
kurz noch mal auf der hohen Politik Herr
Kühnert wie problematisch finden Sie
dass dieses Gefühl ich will nicht
gedrängt werden ich möchte mir in Ruhe
Zeit lassen ich möchte mich nicht durch
die Zeit oder wütende Menschen zu sehr
schieben lassen dass das auch diesen
Kanzler und damit auch seinem Land
schaden könnte sowohl in dem
ich lasse mir Zeit beim besetzen selbst
einer solchen Personalie als auch eben
in dieser großen Frage wie der Westen
reagiert auf alles was die Ukraine jetzt
gerade braucht dieses Image er will sich
nicht treiben lassen er möchte die Dinge
überleben und überlegt Entschuldigung
überlegen und in Ruhe überleben wir auch
nicht schlecht überlegen die
hinterlassen ja eben nicht das Gefühl
dass das jetzt alles ganz überlegt ist
sondern in der Regel tun wir die Dinge
wir tun sie spät wir tun sie obwohl sie
vorher noch ganz anders erzählt haben so
also schadet er seinem Image in dem er
so lange zögert ist die Frage egal jetzt
ob Lambrecht oder Leos es wäre fatal
wenn er auf in erster Linie auf sein
Image gucken würde in dieser ganzen
Angelegenheit oder Scholz hat wie heute
auch der Verteidigungsminister ein
Amtseid geschworen und er legt ihn so
aus wie er das für richtig hält er hat
immer wieder seine Grundsätze dargelegt
ich weiß es hängt in solchen runden ein
zu den Ohren raus aber für die Menschen
im Land ist das wichtig dass wir nicht
zur Kriegspartei werden dass es nicht
auf Kosten unserer eigenen
Verteidigungsfähigkeit die bescheiden
genug aussieht gehen soll und dass wir
in enger Koordinierung mit unseren
wichtigsten internationalen Partnern
vorgehen und auf dieser Grundlage haben
sich die Entscheidung immer weiter
entwickelt wir dürfen nicht vergessen
bevor die russischen Truppen
am 24 Februar letzten Jahres
einmarschiert sind gab es eine klare
politische und gesellschaftliche
Mehrheit in Deutschland das
Waffenlieferung in kriegs- und
Krisengebiete dass das nicht sein soll
dass das hier nicht zu suchen hat die
Politik hat wie auch die Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft damals ihre Position in
Anbetracht der Entwicklung der Bilder
der Völkerrecht und allem was
dazugehörte geändert begründet geändert
und seitdem haben sich unsere Hilfen
neben den humanitären und finanziellen
eben auch militärisch immer weiter
entwickelt aber woran Olaf Scholz
gelegen ist
weil er wie wir alle auch Umfragen lesen
kann und weiß dass jetzt gerade Anfang
des Jahres wieder einer kläglicher Teil
der deutschen und diesen Umfragen
Glauben schenken darf gesagt hat dass
sie das vom Grundsatz her weiterhin
nicht ganz geheuer ist mit den vielen
Waffenlieferung ihm ist klar dass er für
den Zusammenhalt dieser Gesellschaft den
es übrigens auch für eine gute unter
Ukraine unterstützungspolitik braucht
dass er dafür fortwährend
argumentieren und nachweisen muss dass
er seine Versprechen dir abgegeben hat
nicht bricht das als zögerlich
darstellen dann muss er und müssen wir
das auch als Sozialdemokratie ertragen
und das halten wir auch aus so wir
werden auch darüber noch mal reden auch
über die Historien natürlich noch mal
reden auch ob Angela Merkel das
irgendwie so anders gemacht hat ob die
auch so viel gegen Umfragen in ihrem
Land regiert hat oder regiert hätte aber
nun ist das Leben ja hässlich
wiederwertig und konkret und gerade
reden wir über die Leos und die scheinen
mehr zu sein als im Zentrum zu stehen
sie sind der Elefanten er ist der
Elefant im Raum nur Deutschland kann die
Lieferung des Leopard 2 an die Ukraine
freigeben selbst das EU-Parlament
fordert den Kampfpanzer für Kiew in
Davos machen sie Druck Polen Finn
Littauer
wir hoffen dass die Deutschen die die
Panzer ja herstellen mitmachen und
liefern
alle hängen an den Lippen des Kanzlers
doch der bleibt mal wieder schmalleckig
[Musik]
wir werden die Ukraine so lange wie
nötig unterstützen
denn der Kanzler macht nichts ohne die
USA nur wenn beiden seinen Kampfpanzer
liefert gibt es auch den Leopard 2 wir
müssen da vorangehen und wir müssen im
Geleitzug jetzt auch die Leopard 2
liefern das Problem mit jeder Lieferung
an Kiew die Bundeswehr gibt ab und
blutet aus die Rüstungsindustrie kann
frühestens im Herbst liefern und
bestellt wurde sowieso noch nichts
jetzt ist ganz interessant Frau Güler
das ausgerechnet die Union sagt dass Leo
1 Leo 2 Leo 1 aus der Industrie Leo zwei
aus der Bundeswehr geliefert werden kann
das sagten nicht nur Herr Dobrindt und
Herr Söder in Seeon sondern wurde durch
diese Wetter bestätigt das auch
sie sind sich sicher dass das eben in
Größenordnung geschehen kann und das ist
geschehen muss mit zusammen mit den
anderen Verbündeten ja also jetzt
vielleicht einmal zu den Umfragen die
Umfragen würden vielleicht auch etwas
anders auffallen ausfallen wenn wir
einen Kanzler hätten der erklären kann
gerade sehr sehr gut warum ist wichtig
ist dass wir die Ukraine weiterhin
unterstützen und warum ist auch wichtig
ist dass wir die Ukraine jetzt mit
Kampfpanzern unterstützen aber der
Bundeskanzler wird in dieser Frage ja
von dieser Gesellschaft überwiegend als
zögern angenommen insofern würde ich
sagen dabei ist sich die Katze schon in
den Schwanz also insofern darf man sich
da glaube ich jetzt nicht auf die
Umfragen fokussieren weil die Umfragen
könnten auch anders sein wenn der
Kanzler in der Lage wäre das so zu
erklären seinem Volk gegenüber wie ist
die Briten tun wie es Polen tut wie ist
die baltischen Staaten tun sofern ist
das für mich jetzt kein Argument und was
die Kampfpanzer betrifft ja wir haben
heute auch über unseren Antrag im Plenum
dazu debattiert und wir halten die
Lieferung richtig es ist aber nur ein
verlor ab das muss man ganz klar sagen
weil die Hauptfrage auf die wir uns
glaube ich auch fokussieren müssen auch
morgen in Sonnenstein ist die globale
bzw die geopolitische Dimension des
ganzen was passiert wenn die Ukraine
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnt und diese
Antwort ist so brutal vielschichtig oder
die Antworten können so brutal
vielschichtig sein die ganz klar unsere
Sicherheit in Europa gefährden können
die Antworten und deshalb ist die
kampfpanzerlieferung eigentlich nur ein
Follower ab wo wir sagen wenn wir die
Ukraine jetzt neben den Schützenpanzern
auch mit Kampfpanzern ausstatten ist das
eigentlich nur die logische Schlussfolge
damit sich die Ukraine selbst
verteidigen kann weil es gibt eine rote
Linie in diesem Krieg und die rote Linie
ist dass wir selbst niemals zu
Kriegspartei werden dürfen indem wir
selbst Soldaten hinschicken wenn wir das
allerdings nicht machen müssen wir die
Ukraine entsprechend ausstatten und dazu
gehören neben den Schützenpanzern
eigentlich auch Kampfpanzer ideal wäre
es bei den Leo 2 eigentlich weil da
bräuchten wir nur eine Ausbildung mein
sie dürfen ja nicht denken wenn wir Leo
1 das kann ihn Herr Masala viel besser
erklären aber wenn sie Lego 1 Lego 2
Challenger Abrams schicken dass das eine
Ausbildung ist demnächst haben wir den
ganzen ukrainischen Soldaten in den
europäischen Ländern eigentlich
Ausbildung und niemand steht mir an der
Front deswegen wäre es gut wenn man sich
Morgen darauf einigt neben den 14
Challenger die die Briten zugesagt haben
dass man sich auch ein kanzlermodell
einig äh auf eine Einzelmodell einig und
idealerweise wäre das der Leo zwei wir
sind und Herr kühn hat weiß schon dass
er das am Ende natürlich gefragt werden
wird der kleine Borghoff bei der Frage
warum sagen die Amerikaner heute so
Apotheken Tisch das ist von Ihrer Seite
die Abrams nicht sein werden und das ist
eine souveräne Entscheidung der
Deutschen ist dieses europäische
Bataillon oder konzilium anzuführen dass
dann aus verschieden anderen Ländern den
Kampfpanzer schicken wird erklären Sie
uns wenn Sie können dieses Spiel in
Anführungsstrichen diesen Gedanken der
Amerikaner die Amerikaner haben ja eine
in Hülle und Fülle Material geschickt
sie haben auch die Wirksamkeit des der
Waffen ständig gesteigert sind auch
dabei das wieder zu tun aber sie haben
immer gesagt dass sie die Abram Panzer
nicht liefern werden die zu kompliziert
sind die für diesen Zweck nicht geeignet
sind die vor Ort schwer reparierbar sind
das ist der amerikanische Grund am
Anfang waren sie so zurückhaltend wie
die Bundesregierung auch überhaupt
gegenüber der panzerlieferung das haben
sie vom Monaten aufgegeben und seit
Monaten ist klar dass die Amerikaner
nicht nur die Deutschen und die anderen
Europäer des in Ordnung finden wenn sie
es tun würden die an einer Art Leopard
Konsortium zu bilden sondern sie das
darin ermutigen seit der Außenminister
gesagt das hat die Botschafter gesagt ja
dass sie sich da eine Führungsrolle der
deutschen wünschen und wenn Olaf Scholz
nun formuliert dass wir diesen Leo 2
aber nur schicken wenn die Amerikaner
den Abrams schicken dann verunmöglicht
er mit dieser Aussage dass er überhaupt
irgendwas tun muss ja also ob er das
gesagt hat das wissen wir nur aus
Zeitungsberichten von dem neuen
Verteidigungsminister wissen wir dass es
dieses Jugendteam nicht gäbe ich glaube
dass wir morgen in in Ramstein an ein
wesentlichen Wendepunkt geraten wenn das
morgen schief geht dann haben wir ein
Scherbenhaufen ja wir haben einen
Scherbenhaufen in der Allianz putin wird
sich die Hände reiben deswegen darf das
Morgen nicht schief gehen und es ist
glaube ich auch die Aufgabe der
Amerikaner die diese Koalition und diese
Allianz geschmiedet haben die haben
Monate vor dem Krieg darauf
verwandt die Europäer zusammen zu
bringen und sie haben seitdem die
Europäer zusammenzubringen das würde ich
morgen auch erhoffen dass wir in
Kompromissvorschlag haben der den
Ukrainern hilft und die Allianz nicht
auseinandertreibt die Bundesrepublik
geht es um drei Sachen zu ermöglichen
dass es eine Frühjahrsoffensive der
Ukrainer geben kann es wird um die
Zukunft der deutschen Rüstungsindustrie
morgen gehen wenn denn wenn morgen nein
gesagt werden wird dann wird ja niemand
mehr irgendwann mal einen deutschen
Panzer kaufen wollen die Polen wollen
das schon jetzt nicht tun und zu dritten
ist die Verlässlichkeit deutsche
Außenpolitik Vertrauen baut man lange
auf kann man schnell verspielen auch das
steht morgen zu diskutieren
uns auch das noch mal mit Leo 1 Leo 2 es
gibt einen alten Leopard der äußern sich
jetzt auch alle möglichen dazu dass der
auch von der Industrie hergerichtet
werden könnte und zwar in Größenordnung
80 Stück glaube ich würde Mannschaften
in den nächsten 20 Monaten und man würde
schneller
noch weitere Zehen schaffen und beim
Leopard 2 wissen wir dass es eigentlich
das modernere Gerät ist würde dieser Leo
1 denn noch einen Unterschied machen
oder
der Leo 1 würde sozusagen dazu dienen
das zu machen was die Ukrainer mit ihrem
Panzern bisher sehr häufig machen
nämlich die als eine Art
ersatzartillerie zu benutzen also neben
der normalen Artillerie sozusagen mit
dem Leo Ziele zu beschießen der Leo 1
wäre aber nicht in der Lage gegen die
moderneren
T-72 T90 sollen jetzt auch sozusagen an
die Front gefahren werden der Russen in
einem klassischen panzerduell zu
bestehen das heißt also da würden wir
was liefern was sozusagen nicht die
Quantität die Qualität hätte der
russischen Quantität zu bestehen das
kann dann halt nur der Leo 2 und der der
zwei A5 wird es sein nicht der zwei A7
nicht das neueste Modell sondern das
Vorgängermodell
der ist um den es geht weil nur der
sozusagen die Qualität hat der
russischen Quantität zu widerstehen und
ihr entgegenzutreten und dann in
Kombination natürlich mit der Infanterie
mit den Schützenpanzern möglicherweise
gegen offensiven die dazu führen
sozusagen das territ Museum dass die
Russen jetzt besetzt halten
zurückzuholen was stimmt es gibt die
einen die sagen dass sich die Amerikaner
und die deutschen darauf verständigt
haben dass man jetzt erstmal schauen
will wie der Bradley wie der Marder wie
der AMX der Franzosen bei den Russen
aufgenommen und darauf reagiert wird und
man nicht sofort auch mit dem Leopard
hinterherkommen möchte das lese ich und
man liest auf der anderen Seite dass die
Polen zwar öffentlich erklären dass sie
das jetzt auch alleine machen werden und
dass sie sich auch an diese Genehmigung
durch die Deutschen nicht mehr gebunden
sehen will und überhaupt endlich die
Leos geliefert werden müssen und haben
noch keinen Antrag gestellt was davon
stimmt was ist richtig was ist Politik
also sag mal so dass sie keine Antrag
gestellt haben das stimmt aber sie
stellen auch nur dann einen Antrag wenn
sie wissen dass der genehmigt wird also
sie stellen einfach nicht einen Antrag
mal ins Blaue hinaus und zu warten das
dann irgendjemand entscheidet doch nicht
genehmigt wird das ist ja für Sie dann
eine Klatsche ins Gesicht also sie
stellen diesen Antrag erst wenn sie
wissen der geht durch soll das ist der
formale Prozess deswegen haben die Polen
keinen gestellt weil sie darauf warten
dass sie das grüne Licht bekommen dass
sie die Leos dahin liefern können
ich glaube nicht dass man es sich
leisten kann jetzt zu gucken wie der
Bradley performt und der Marder performt
wir stehen vorm Frühling Russen
massieren massiv auf die Ukrainer das
muss man sagen im Don was haben
erhebliche Verluste wir wissen momentan
nicht wie stark diese Armee eigentlich
noch ist also Schätzungen gehen die
existiert noch zwischen 100.000 und
130.000 Mann
da jetzt noch Monate zu warten um zu
gucken was passiert mit dem Marder was
passiert mit dem Bradley würde letzten
Endes das Risiko beinhalten dass diese
Armee noch weiter geschwächt wird und
dann bringen auch die Leonie Lieferung
nichts mehr also von daher der ist sehr
viel Politik dabei aber ich glaube
sozusagen die dieser sukzessive Ansatz
zu gucken was bringen die Lieferungen
die jetzt gerade entschieden worden sind
der ist schon mal nicht richtig weil das
ganze eigentlich irgend normalerweise
genau und dann sind wir Herr Kühnert bei
der zentralen Frage Herr kleine
Brockhoff hat die Rampe schon gebaut
wird es morgen frage ich den
Generalsekretär der Kanzlerpartei wird
es morgen in Ramstein eine
Koalition geben von Ländern die sich
verabreden dem russischen Diktator
Vladimir Putin jetzt ein Kontingent an
Leopard 2 Panzern entgegenzusetzen womit
rechnen Sie
das kann ich Ihnen hier nicht
beantworten weil wenn das alles schon
fest stehen würde müsste man kein
Treffen mehr abhalten und es geht ja
auch nicht nur um diese Frage bei dem
Treffen sondern zwischen dutzenden
Partnern um eine kontinuierliche
Abstimmung um Logistikfragen Munition
und vieles mehr das ist eine wichtige
Frage das verstehe ich schon ich will
das jetzt nicht wegdrücken oder mir
einen schlanken Fuß machen aber es ist
wie so oft in den letzten Tagen gesagt
wird auch nicht die Wunderwaffe die den
Krieg entscheiden wird sondern es ist
eine von vielen Fragen und das ist so
ist es kein Game changer also ich meine
wir reden wir reden über ein Paket wenn
man richtig zählt zwischen weiß ich
nicht die Zahlen sind unterschiedlich 60
bis 80 Leos die dann geliefert werden
würden das hinter mag mich der
Koordinaten ungefähr zwei bataillen also
und die haben eine 1.300 km lange Front
zwei Bataillone nach deutschen Einsatz
Grundsätzen sind glaube ich zwei
bataione sind für zehn Quadratkilometer
gedacht haben wir eigentlich letzte
Woche auch schon gesprochen und können
sagen das wird diesen Krieg sicherlich
nicht gewinnen oder verlieren machen und
dennoch ist wieder die Frage Herr
Kühnert wenn vor sieben Tagen der
Vizekanzler Robert Habeck sagt dass
Deutschland sich nicht in den Weg
stellen wird wenn andere Länder
Entscheidungen treffen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen unabhängig davon welche wir
treffen warum sagt er das vor sieben
Tagen und warum ist es so schwer diese
Auffassung zu sein nämlich dass wenn
Länder eine eigene Form der
Unterstützung entscheiden wollen sie
darin nicht zu behindern und warum sagt
omed nuripur gestern dass die
leolieferung eigentlich geprüft und
möglich sein und ist jetzt eigentlich
nur noch das gutes Kanzlers fehlt also
ihre eigenen Ampel Kollegen ich kann
jetzt nicht auch noch die Grünen mit
erklären also
müssen erklären warum irgendwie eben auf
die Grünen nicht hört er könnte ja
wenigstens sagen sind meine Partner der
Vizekanzler wird es nicht einfach so
erklären weil wir jetzt auch über den
Kanzler hier viel gesprochen haben und
das ist ja jedem freigestellt sein
eigenes framing zu benutzen und vom
Zauberer oder Zögerer zu sprechen im
Kabinett gilt
Kollegialitätsprinzip Dinge werden
zwischen dem fachlich zuständigen
Ministerium oder den Ministerien und dem
Kanzler besprochen aber am Ende gilt
eben auch die Richtlinienkompetenz die
Gesamtverantwortung trägt der
Bundeskanzler und die übte auch aus und
das hat er ja schon früh auch in diesem
Krieg gesagt manchmal übt man die auch
aus indem man nicht das tut was etwas
was jemand jetzt gerade erwartet oder
einfordert sondern indem man noch
stimmen einholt Olaf Scholz redet auch
von Beginn an andauernd ja selbst mit
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten das ist
auch nichts was wegen Christine
Lambrecht passiert ist sondern das habe
ich zu erwarten von dem deutschen
Bundeskanzler dass er mit den USA und
dem dortigen Präsidenten das sind mit
unsere wichtigsten Partner im
internationalen Raum nicht nur in der
Bearbeitung dieses Krieges dass er mit
dem unmittelbaren persönlichen Austausch
ist und immer dann wenn wir in den
letzten Monaten Schritte gemacht haben
ob das bei den mehrfach Raketenwerfern
der Fall gewesen ist ob das bei den
Flugabwehr geparaten gewesen ist damals
das ist immer auf solche Koordinierung
zurückgegangen und wir sollten uns bitte
auch nichts einreden lassen die deutsche
Unterstützung ist ein gedenkt der
Tatsache dass unsere Möglichkeiten
limitiert sind aus Gründen ist massiv
die USA sind weit vorne weg die haben
auch ein mehr als zehnfaches an
Verteidigungsetat was die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat und danach kommen in
Qualität und Quantität Deutschland und
Großbritannien zusammen und das darf man
auch mal da darf man mal innehalten und
das festhalten damit nicht alle heute
Abend wieder schlafen gehen und das
Gefühl haben unsere Bundesrepublik
Deutschland tut gar nichts für die
Ukraine das Gegenteil ist der Fall darf
ich ganz kurz was sagen sie haben völlig
recht also Deutschland liefert total
viel das Problem ist nur das von Tag
eins des Krieges die strategische
Kommunikation dieser Regierung über die
Frage was liefert Deutschland wie
unterstützt grotten schlecht ist und das
hat sich bis heute nicht geändert und
deswegen entsteht der Eindruck dass
sozusagen wir eigentlich nicht viel
liefern ja und dann geht es um die
großen Fragen also Raketenwerfer ne da
sozusagen lange Diskussion jetzt le
Schaden ich bin ganz bei Ihnen
Deutschland liefert sehr viel und unter
den Europäern sicherlich sehr weit oben
aber kommunizieren tut das diese
Regierung nicht besonders gut und
deshalb entsteht der Eindruck dass wir
eigentlich so wenig tun für die UK okay
und dann trotzdem Entschuldigung liefert
viel aber auch immer mit dem Eindruck
dass es auf Zug der Verbündeten passiert
das ist auf internationalem Druck
passiert das darf man natürlich werden
ja ja genau wir haben sie wissen dass
Herr Kühnert wir haben beide die Hand
für denselben Antrag gehoben wir haben
Ende April im Deutschen Bundestag einen
Antrag verabschiedet wo wir auch von
schweren Waffen sprechen also insofern
sind auch schwere Waffen geliefert
worden aber beim beim Kampfpanzer hat
der Kanzler von Anfang an eine rote
Linie gezogen und kann eigentlich nicht
erklären wieso diese diese Linie
existiert und trotzdem jetzt noch mal
vielleicht zu den Virus um kurz
zurückzukommen wir hätten die
Möglichkeit sehr schnell zu liefern
indem wir nicht nur die Industrie
beauftragen das hätte eigentlich schon
im Sommer passieren müssen oder schon am
24 Februar passieren müssen wir können
den singt Tausch jetzt mal etwas weiter
denken wir können Griechenland Fragen
die verfügen über 300 Leo 2 Panzer dass
sie 10 15 je nachdem an die Ukraine
liefern und dafür die 10-15 von uns
bekommen wenn du Industrie ein Jahr
braucht und sie instand zu setzen wir
können das jetzt sehr sehr schnell
machen wir können Polen bitten weitere
als die angesagten 14 zu liefern die
haben auch ungefähr die Tschechen haben
selbst keine die Tschechien haben
zugesagt bekommen von uns ähm wenn sie
ja genau genau die dauern allerdings
auch noch ein bisschen ich glaube bisher
hat Tschechien letztes Jahr im Dezember
ein ein Modell geliefert bekommen macht
jetzt nicht wirklich den Braten dick
aber die Blender in in der Natur es gibt
Länder in der NATO die leopartze haben
die Instanz sind die direkt geliefert
werden könnten griechenland habe ich
genannt Polen habe ich genannt die
Türkei gehört dazu also wir können hier
auch etwas anders denken damit das jetzt
Einsatz noch ja
polnische Ministerpräsident hat gestern
in Davos etwas ganz ganz entscheidendes
gesagt wir haben nicht den Luxus für
weitere Verzögerungen es geht um ganz
ganz viel natürlich sind die Leos keine
gamechanger sie schützen aber die
Menschen vor Ort und das darf man glaube
ich nicht vergessen diese Idee ist ja
auch an ihnen irgendwie nicht
vorübergezogen Herr kühner sie ist nicht
neu zu sagen wir könnten ein solches
Konsortium auch anführen die Deutschen
könnten das Koordinieren sie müssten gar
nicht das meiste liefern aber sie
könnten es anführen und könnten dafür
sorgen dass eben eine nennenswerte Zahl
von Leos zusammenkommen da treffen sich
morgen 50 Länder die
Verteidigungsminister was müsste denn
Deutschland in diesem Hut packen denken
sie damit das ein akzeptabler
Anteil damit das ein zentabler Beitrag
Deutschlands würde auf diesem Treffen
oder sagen Sie da jetzt auch das
interessiert sich nicht oder das wissen
sie nicht ich habe an keiner Stelle
heute abend gesagt dass mich irgendwas
nicht interessiert dann wäre ich nicht
hierher gekommen ich finde ja
Verteidigungsminister hat es vorhin im
Interview heute journal ja sehr gut
deutlich gemacht es geht insbesondere um
die Achse mit den Vereinigten Staaten
man kann das albern finden und sagen
warum jetzt ausgerechnet die man kann
aber auch wenn ich einfach hinnehmen das
ist für viele Menschen in Deutschland
durchaus auch ja ich glaube durchaus
auch einen symbolhaft wichtigen
Charakter zu wissen wir sind an der
Seite der Amerikaner die Amerikaner sind
an unserer Seite gerade aufgrund ihrer
massiven Unterstützung diese leisten
dürfen nicht vergessen viele die uns
jetzt hingelegt werden als Argument in
den letzten Wochen zum Teil ja Monaten
bieten vergleichsweise wenig an wenn
mich darüber nicht erheben aber muss das
mal festhalten die Spanier das ist ja
seit Monaten im Gespräch bieten kaum 20
Panzer an von denen sehr strittig ist ob
sie überhaupt in einer ansatzweise
adäquaten Zeit in Schuss gebracht werden
könnten und dann weiterhelfen die
Franzosen können von Ihrem Modell da
geht es nicht um Leos eine sehr sehr
geringe zweistellige Stückzahl
wahrscheinlich entbehren die Briten
haben jetzt eine niedrige zweistellige
Zahl an Kampfpanzern angekündigt die
Polen kündigen verbal etwas an Stellen
den Antrag nicht stellen ins
Schaufenster am Ende interessiert sie
vielleicht gar nicht wie Deutschland das
votiert man kann sich dem Eindruck nicht
ganz verwehren bei allem Respekt das
vielleicht der innerpolnische Wahlkampf
eine kleine Randrolle auch spielen
könnte in dieser Angelegenheit und da
ist es dann wenn ich das alles zusammen
nehme schon nicht unwichtig immer auch
den Blick über den großen Teich zu
richten und zu sagen inwieweit sind wir
koordiniert mit einem unserer größten
und wichtigsten Partner sind ja an der
Seite der deutschen also Artikel 5 das
nato-vertrags sagt dass die Amerikaner
in einem Fall einer Aggression
deutschland und die anderen Verbündeten
schützen müssen also darum mauert man
sich ein kettet sich an die Zusage der
Abrams Panzer und nimmt sich dadurch
ganz viele andere strategische Optionen
weil jetzt sind eigentlich nur noch
schlechte Optionen übrig es kann Scholz
entweder wenn es doch zu einer
leolieferung kommen sollte seine Zusage
kassieren dass er nur liefert wenn die
Abrams oder die Amerikaner im
Gleichschritt vorangehen oder er kann
sich er kann zulassen dass andere die
Leos liefern indem er Ausfuhrgenehmigung
für Drittstaaten erteilt aber selber
nicht mitmachen sieht auch blöd aus
sonst auch das Bündnis gespalten im
schlimmsten Fall sogar sagen wir machen
beides nicht wir liefern nicht und wir
teilen die Genehmigung nicht und dann
ist es wirklich ein Bruch in diesen
Bündnis wenn dann die anderen alleine
voranschreiten und in diese missliche
Lage und jetzt so kurz vor diesem
wichtigen Terminen hat man sich selber
gebracht indem man eben diese Verkettung
immer wieder machen
der Bundeskanzler hat ja erstmal Deutsch
amerikanische Verhältnis repariert indem
er sich von Nord Stream verabschiedet
hat und indem man zwei Prozent ange
gekündigt hat und indem er sich an die
Seite der Amerikaner gestellt hat in den
abwägungsprozessen der letzten Monat nur
jetzt sind wir in der Lage gekommen wo
es ja nicht mehr darum geht an der Seite
der Amerikaner sozusagen sondern sich im
Verhältnis zu den anderen Europäer zu
isolieren und das ist Deutschland darf
nicht die verhinderungsmacht sein das
ist der das Problem vor dem wir vor dem
wir jetzt stehen vielleicht noch ein
zweiter Gedanke warum diese Leos
politisch wichtig sind Putin möchte auf
Zeit setzen er glaubt der Westen ist
schwach der Westen hält nicht durch wir
werden klein beigeben deswegen ist es so
wichtig ihm ein Zeichen zu geben das in
Hinsicht auf industrierende Kapazität wo
er nicht mithalten kann wir wissen nicht
deswegen braucht man dieses Signal
deswegen ist es nicht nur kampfkapazität
sicher ist keine Wunderwaffe aber es ist
das Zeichen dass man länger weitermachen
wird und das nächste was man dann
brauchen wird ist man muss industriel
die Kapazität für Munition und ähnliches
hochfahren jetzt gibt es jemanden der
schon fast zynisch schmunzeln muss tippe
ich in Erfurt darf ich an dieser Stelle
heute Abend sehr herzlich André Wüstner
zu uns bitten den Chef des
Bundeswehrverbandes Herr wüsner sie
haben das natürlich alles verfolgt und
sie kennen auf der anderen Seite die
Situation in der Bundeswehr würden Sie
denn ganz persönlich gefragt und es ist
dann eine praktisch berufliche Frage
würden sie diese Leos die die deutsche
Bundeswehr heute hat denn hergeben
aus der Bundeswehr aktuell aus meiner
Sichtweise Blickwinkel deutscher
Bundesverband auf keinen Fall also
vollkommen klar wir müssen die Ukraine
unterstützen ich bin auch der Auffassung
egal was morgen entschieden wird ich
würde nicht von einem Scherbenhaufen
sprechen sondern das wird ein Format von
vielen sein in dieser Krieg wird im
Sommer noch nicht vorbei sein wird
weiterhin koordinieren müssen was man
weiterführend liefert zur Debatte um die
Leoparden auch das ist mir verkürzt nur
sich auf ein Waffensystem zu
konzentrieren es braucht immer ein
gesamtpuzzle und nicht nur ein
Puzzlestück das wird gerade koordiniert
elementar ist beispielsweise Atelier
flugkörperabwehr und dieses Puzzle
stellt man gerade zusammen dennoch
glaube ich wird man irgendwann über die
Schwelle Leopard gehen müssen jetzt zum
Thema panzerbalione wir haben aktuell
sechs panzerbataillone in der Bundeswehr
eigentlich sollte ein panzerbaillon 44
Kampfpanzer haben viel von diesen Sex
haben weniger als zehn einsatzbereit man
könnte natürlich den Inspektor des
Heeres von seinem Auftrag entbinden und
sagen Landesverteidigung mit Blick auf
die Panzerbataillon ist nicht mehr
gefordert aber das einfach ein Unding
und deswegen wenn dann muss man sich auf
die Industrie konzentrieren das sage ich
jetzt seit einem Jahr dann muss man die
rüstungskapazitäten hochfahren und dann
kann man auch ein Verbund mit den
anderen den Typ 2 A4 den alle anderen
haben den man logistisch versorgen kann
entsprechend zu liefern einsetzen und
die entsprechenden Ersatzteile liefern
alles andere greift zu kurz das ist so
interessant sie sagen wir haben nichts
und wir haben nichts was funktioniert
oder sie sagen was wir haben geben wir
eigentlich nicht gerne her dann steht
Herr Wüstner nicht nur der Bundeskanzler
auf der Bremse sondern eigentlich auch
Sie
nein auf keinen Fall also wenn ich jetzt
mal die Truppe sehe da ist man ja
grundsätzlich davon überzeugt dass wir
unterstützen müssen nichtsdestotrotz
haben wir unseren nato-verpflichtung
aktuell schon an der Ostflanke wir haben
unsere Einsätze wie in Mali wir haben
das was auf was wir uns vorbereiten
müssen 2025 und wir sind mehr oder
weniger nackt die Lage in der Bundeswehr
ist Verkehr sie ist so schwierig wie
noch nie zuvor und ist auch eine Frage
wie die Bundesregierung mit der eigenen
Landes und Bündnis
verteidigungsaufgabe umgeht im Rahmen
der NATO im Rahmen der
Landesverteidigung und deswegen muss man
abwägen aber viel wichtiger ist dass man
endlich zuliefert alles was wir
abgegeben Stichwort Artillerie das muss
endlich wieder neu zugeliefert werden
und da fehlen Verträge und da ist
Politik grundsätzlich noch zu langsam
hier wird heftig genutzt in der Runde
Herr Masala was ist fragt sich der Leier
eigentlich so schwer daran diese Dinge
zu bestellen Sie vorzuhalten Sie
rechtzeitig genug zu bestellen und das
was man abgeben möchte auch gleich
wieder zu bestellen damit man es wieder
hat
ich glaube thomas kleinebrockhoff hat
etwas absolut richtiges gesagt am ganz
am Anfang dieser Sendung und zwar mit
Blick auf diese lng-terminals wo in
einer rasenden Geschwindigkeit für
bundesrepublikanische Verhältnisse
dieses Problem sozusagen gelöst wurde
und das lng-terminal gekommen ist gehen
wir auf die sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik
agiert dieses System BMVg Bundeswehr
Industrie noch immer so als ob wir am
23.02 werden das heißt wir agieren wie
in Friedenszeiten wir sind aber in
Krisenzeiten und wir haben keinerlei
Strukturen die sozusagen beschleunigt
für Krisenzeiten reagieren können und da
kommt beim Herrn Hübner ne warum ist
nicht mit der Industrie schon viel
früher geredet worden warum gibt es noch
keine Zulieferung warum sind Verträge
nicht geschlossen worden weil wir das
ganze System noch so machen als ob es
diesen Krieg nicht geben würde also ob
es diesen Krieg mit all seinen
Notwendigkeit nicht geben würde und das
ist genau der Punkt wo ich sage eine der
Aufgaben von des neuen
Verteidigungsminister wird es sein weil
dieser Krieg uns noch mindestens ein
Jahr begleiten wird genau diese
Strukturen herzustellen genau sozusagen
koordiniertes Vorgehen mit der
Rüstungsindustrie zu vereinbaren das
genau diese Probleme beschleunigt und
das ist genau das was ich sage so
zeitländer gibt in politisch
außenpolitisch oder
verteidigungspolitisch haben wir keine
Zeiten Wände weil dieses ganze System
bewegt sich noch so als ob Russland die
Ukraine nie überfallen hätte dazu und
dann trotzdem noch mal zusammengedacht
mit der internationalen Aufgabe Herr
Wüstner andere Länder finden ja sehr
wohl Lösungen entschuldigung wenn ich
das so sage um jetzt möglichst schnell
schweres Gerät und eben auch Kampfpanzer
in die Ukraine liefern zu wollen indem
sie es von anderen Staaten kaufen indem
sie regentauscher ermöglichen
untereinander so wie Frau Bühler das
auch gerade dargestellt hat Herr kühne
zuvor auch was ist eigentlich das
Problem daran dass die Bundeswehr das
genauso macht
ja der Punkt ist einfach der der
angesprochen ist die Lage ist prekär wir
sind bei einer einsatzbereitschaftslage
im Bereich von 33% 40% je nach
Waffensystem das kann man jetzt noch
unterscheiden aber der Punkt ist der der
Punkt ist der das was gerade
angesprochen wird es ist noch nicht
verstanden worden dass wir in einer Art
Kriegswirtschaft müssen ich will nicht
sagen dass Siemensstadt Kühlschränke
Munition produzieren muss aber der Punkt
ist der wir müssen jetzt beschleunigen
mit Blick auf die Industrie bei allen
Schi Herz geklappt das muss jetzt auch
bei der Industrie klappen wenn das nicht
funktioniert wenn man sich mal überlegt
was gerade in Russland vorbereitet wird
die Mobilisierung all das was wir jetzt
an Gerät sehen was kommt manche glauben
das ist im Mai im Juni im Juli vorbei
nein das wird länger gehen und wir
müssen endlich Gas geben wenn darüber
diskutiert wird eine Munitionsfabrik von
mir aus in Sachsen zu eröffnen dann
können wir nicht über zwei Jahre
genehmungsverfahren sprechen wir müssen
jetzt Gas geben weil wir auch im
europäischen Verbund kaum genügend
Ersatz und austauscht Teile haben auch
für den Leopard
viele andere Systeme und weil wir kaum
noch Munition haben und das muss Politik
verstehen aber ich bin bei ihnen Politik
hat teilweise den Schuss noch nicht
gehört Herr kleine Brocker sie wissen
doch dass das was sie gerade sagen Jahre
dauern wird da ist der Ukraine Krieg
vorbei das heißt es muss ja Lösungen
geben die auch vorher
funktionieren und da habe ich heute
gehört dass die die Dänen jetzt
Panzerhaubitzen liefern 19 an der
zahlen dann sind sie in ihren Worten zu
reden blank
wir wollen das nicht sie wollen das
nicht ich habe den neuen
Verteidigungsminister in seinen wenigen
Worten heute so verstanden dass er auch
ausbeständen der Bundeswehr liefern muss
und wir sehen ja zum Beispiel an ihren
Äußerungen das ist auch in der
Bundeswehr dagegen Widerstand gibt und
ich glaube auch da wird ein gewisses
Umdenken notwendig sein die müssen eben
auch da wenn ich das vielleicht sagen
darf es ist vollkommen klar also ich
nehme jetzt mal die Panzer bitte die wir
geliefert haben da werden jetzt weiter
stillgelegt für die aus für das
Ausschlachten für die
Ersatzteilgewinnung für die Ukraine der
Punkt ist nur wie weit will man gehen
und vor allem die nächste Frage
angenommen wir gehen All-In was ist denn
wenn das nicht reicht wo ist denn die
Strategie dahinter wo müssen wir denn
hin materiell und mit Blick auf die
Unterstützung wenn das nicht reicht das
gefällt mir noch in der Debatte denn
vollkommen klar wir können mit 14 16
Leoparden weiterführend aus der
Industrie rein es wird nicht reichen und
deswegen müssen wir dennoch die
Industrie stärken wir müssen nämlich das
Thema Munition vielleicht mit Südafrika
reden um 155 mm zu bekommen ist alles
auch eine politische Frage wir müssen
uns abstimmen mit den anderen Stichwort
Exportmöglichkeiten aber der Punkt ist
der es muss verstanden werden dass wir
jetzt industriell beschleunigen müssen
und dieser Krieg wird nicht in einem und
nicht in zwei Jahren vorbei sein ist
eine traurige these aber in dieser
Hinsicht will man gerade und kann man
auch so schwer in die Glaskugel gucken
die deutsche begrüßungsindustrie darf
per Gesetz keine Panzer auf Vorrat
produzieren und Bestellungen gibt es von
anderen Ländern auch man müsste
eigentlich auch Gesetze ändern das ist
das was ich sage das ist eine generelle
Erkenntnis was
planungsgenehmigungs- und
einkaufverfahren angeht und das ist mir
auch wirklich wichtig aus Perspektive
der Koalition während wir jetzt hier
schwerpunktmäßig heute Abend über
Rüstungsindustrie sprechen wenn es um
Beschleunigung und Beschaffung geht
reden wir ja ein anderer Stelle was
Energieunabhängigkeit nicht nur bei den
lng-terminals sondern bei den Leitungen
bei dem Aufstellen von hintenrädern bei
der Installation von
photovoltaikapazitäten und so weiter
reden wir über das Leben genau
arbeitet die Regierung daran wird sehr
zeitnah auch ein großes Paket vorlegen
um auf all diesen Bereichen zu
beschleunigen das ist überall
gleichermaßen notwendig ich möchte gerne
zwei Aspekte unterstreichen aus der
Diskussion eben ich habe in Wüsten dass
er aufmerksam zugehört als er über die
Perspektive eben auch seiner Kameradin
und Kameraden gesprochen hat wie das ist
wenn maßgebliche Bestände von dem was da
ist jetzt noch rausgenommen werden ich
will nur die Beobachtungen hinzufügen
das vielleicht manches was wir in den
letzten Tagen aus den Vereinigten
Staaten gehört haben in Bezug auf die
Abrams einer ähnlichen Perspektive auch
dort in den eigenen Truppen unterliegt
da geht es dann vielleicht weniger um
die Frage dass die Abrams mit Gas und
nicht wie die Leos mit Diesel betankt
werden sondern da geht es eben um die
Frage was haben wir eigentlich selber
noch und eine zweite Beobachtung wenn
wir jetzt dazu aufrufen oder einzelne
das tun ist ja legitim zu sagen wir
halten jetzt nicht mehr bestimmte
Kapazitäten noch zurück sondern sie
geben wir geben raus was geht dann
möchte ich einfach darum werben dass wir
uns hineinversetzen was das für Leute
die davon nicht viel Ahnung haben sich
abends meine Talkshow dazu angucken was
das für die bedeutet sich das
vorzustellen wir exponieren uns aus
guten Gründen indem wir einer der
stärksten militärischen Unterstützer
sind und fahren gleichzeitig im selben
Atemzug
verteidigungskapazitäten stark runter
dass da Menschen zu Hause im Sofa sitzen
und vielleicht noch mitkriegen wie in
russischen Staatsmedien neben den USA
vor allem über Deutschland in einer
extremen Art und Weise berichtet wird
als diejenigen die das ganze
vorantreiben die Verteidigung der
Ukraine das da Leute mal innehalten und
gerne politisch erklärt haben wollen ob
das alles vom Ende gut und sicher
durchdacht ist und wir das durchhalten
können ist eine vollkommen legitime
Frage die auch beantwortet werden
noch nutzen weil genau
es ist immer dieses stereotyp und das
ist jetzt erstmal keine Kritikern an dem
grundsätzlich nur mich stört diese
dieser Satz vom Ende her denken weil wir
alle kennen das Ende nicht deswegen kann
auch Olaf Scholz das nicht vom Ende her
denken weil er kennt das Ende genauso
wenig wie sie oder ich das heißt also
sozusagen man muss natürlich darüber
nachdenken was die Schritte sind und
welche Konsequenzen sie haben können
aber man kann nicht argumentieren man
muss das vom Ende denken
interessante Punkte aber kam ja von
Herrn Wüstner zum einen ist die
Dimension noch mal deutlich zu machen
und Wolfgang eschinger der ehemalige
Chef der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
hat ganz kurz mal gesagt was ist
eigentlich bedeutet was allein die
Ukraine pro Tag an Munition braucht
die Ukraine verschießt pro Tag so viel
Munition wie wir in einem halben Jahr
produzieren
so Entschuldigung wenn wir das so
zitieren es war aber ein
Zeitungsinterview und insofern zitieren
wir es eben als text-zitat was heißt das
denn wie schnell kriegt man denn eine
Industrie wieder angeworfen auf den
Zustand so schnell so viel Nachschub zu
organisieren das ist ein also das ist
aber wieder jetzt so das alte System das
wusste man von Anfang an klar das ist
ein Krieger da wird sozusagen viel
Munition verschossen wir wissen seit
Monaten sozusagen wie viel shells die
Russen und die Ukraine schießen und es
passiert relativ wenig um das dann
wieder anzuschmeißen jetzt hat er wüsner
er wüsner von der von den Fabriken
geredet es gibt Überlegungen sozusagen
glaube ich in Rumänien der Fabrik zu
gründen die die 152 mm also das was sie
Artillerie braucht nur wir haben sehr
viel Zeit verloren für Sachen die
abzusehen waren und man muss auch sagen
als die als diese Angriffskrieg begann
Munition ist in der Bundeswehr Problem
dann bewegt sich die Bundeswehr aber sie
kommt zu spät weil andere Staaten bei
den Herstellern die die Munition
herstellen schon längst geordert haben
und die Industrie sagt natürlich ihr
seid Nummer vier stellt euch hinten an
erstmal bedienen wir 1 2 3 4 also
nochmal Friedenszeiten wir waren ein
System oder sind ein System in
Friedenszeiten und wir haben noch nicht
begriffen dass wir in der Krisenzeit
sind wo wir schneller sind müssen noch
die gute Frage danach gestellt wie lange
können wir eigentlich und was passiert
wenn alles was wir der Ukraine anbieten
und geben nicht ausreichen wird gegen
die konventionelle Kraft Russlands das
merken wir uns hier wir müssen ja ich
wollte sie noch mit einem anderen Zitat
von Wolfgang Ischinger nicht
konfrontieren sondern sagen von
Ischinger war ja auch der Gedanke dass
die ukrainische Armee am Ende eine so
gut ausgestattete und eine so hoch
motivierte sein wird dass sie
wahrscheinlich die beste in Europa ist
und eben nicht die deutsche Bundeswehr
und was wäre daran eigentlich so
schlecht
ich würde mir das wünschen weil dann
wäre vollkommen klar dass Putin diesen
Krieg verloren hätte der Punkt ist nur
der ich will das noch mal aufgreifen
Frau ellner wir müssen nicht vom Ende
her denken wir müssen vom Worst Case
ausdenken und da rate ich jedem
Abgeordneten in den
Bundesnachrichtendienst zu gehen und als
ich anzusehen was da gerade passiert ich
will nicht den Menschen Angst machen
aber der Punkt ist damit endlich alle
mal den Schuss hören was da gerade
passiert müssen wir zur Kenntnis nehmen
das weiter mobilisiert wird müssen wir
zu Kenntnis nehmen das weiter mit
Hochdruck in Russland Munition
produziert wird müssen wir zur Kenntnis
nehmen das ist in Abstimmung mit Belarus
weitere panzerlieferung gibt und das ist
nur einfach mein Punkt zu sagen achtung
wir diskutieren über einen Kampfpanzer
mit diskutieren jetzt über die nächste
Phase des Krieges alles wichtig wir
müssen das auf lange Sicht sehen wenn es
besser kommt alles gut aber jetzt vom
Worst Case aus denken können wir und das
ist die letzte schwierige Frage dieser
konventionellen groß macht Russland
eben hinreichend Widerstand
entgegensetzen vielleicht kann ich das
so noch mal in den Raum es ist ja auch
etwas was auch Kissinger nun unbedingt
noch befasst hat das Produkt
Sozialprodukt von von Italien Spanien
Spanien Spanien noch niedriger hast du
mich korrigieren
jedenfalls nicht zu viel
also wenn es darum geht ein
langfristigen Konflikt zu führen sind
die westlichen Staaten immer überlegen
allerdings müssen sie auch das tun was
dazu notwendig ist und nervösner hat das
gesagt generell Zorn hat ja immer darauf
verwiesen in welche potenzielle also
welche konventionelle Kraft das
russische her und die russische Armee
hat und dass sie durchaus auch die
Möglichkeit hätten eine zweite Form zu
eröffnen jetzt wird darüber in Belarus
spekuliert wie groß ist die Gefahr her
also ich sehe es als größer an als ich
noch vor zwei Monaten getan hätte weil
es natürlich ukrainische Kräfte im
Norden binden wird so die dann im Osten
und im Süden fehlen also daher ist es
durchaus vorstellbar das Russland wenn
auch nur in begrenzen Maße sozusagen
ausbilderungsaktionen durchführt weil
dann Kräfte gebunden werden die woanders
fehlen wo grassimo auf 22.12 prioritär
ist der Don Bass wo sozusagen dann die
die wirklich schweren offensiven der
russischen stattfinden werden im Prinzip
werden die schon jetzt gebunden dadurch
dass man die Bevölkerung aber sozusagen
wenn Sie die Grenze übertreten werden
noch mehr Kräfte gebunden und die fehlen
ihm dann was dann und momentan sozusagen
die heftigsten Kämpfe stattfinden wir
sind bei der schweren Frage Herr Kühnert
wozu diese Krieg und wie lange wird
diese Krieg geführt wollen wir nur
standhalten wollen wir dass die Ukraine
standhalten oder wollen wir dass Sie
erfolgreich rückgewinnen was die Russen
erobert haben wir wollen dass Sie
erfolgreich rückgewinnen weil das nach
allem was wir über die ukrainischen
Ziele wissen die definieren Sie ja
selber eine Voraussetzung dafür ist dann
zu einem Frieden zu kommen und das
erscheint mir auch sehr logisch zu sein
und dabei wollen und werden wir Sie auch
weiterhin
unterstützen um sie in diese Position zu
bringen wir haben eben über eine Sache
noch nicht gesprochen die die Russen
auch im Vorteil sind nämlich so perfide
es ist die ethische und moralische
Verkommenheit von Vladimir Putin kommt
ihnen insofern zugute dass er die vielen
Männer die er einfach rein zahlenmäßig
in seiner großen Bevölkerung hat ohne
mit der Wimper zu zucken an die Front
schickt und dort pulverisiert das ist
etwas was eine Nation wie die Ukraine
aus guten Gründen so nicht tut und es
stehen ja auch nicht so viele Menschen
zur Verfügung dafür was wird morgen aus
ihrer Einschätzung Frau Wühler in
Ramstein Geschehen ja ich hoffe dass
die Entscheidung getroffen wird nicht
nur einmal zu verkünden was alle Staaten
liefern es ist nicht wenig da bin ich
komplett bei ihnen der
US-Verteidigungsminister ist mit einem
Paket und über Volumen von 2,2
Milliarden gekommen also es ist sehr
viel ohne Abrams 2,2 Milliarden also es
ist nicht so dass nichts passiert aber
ich glaube diese Entscheidung ist
genauso wichtig dass jetzt auch mit den
Verbündeten zusammen nicht im Alleingang
mit den Verbündeten zusammen Kampfpanzer
geliefert werden es gibt verschiedene
Möglichkeiten ohne an die Bestände der
Bundeswehr zu gehen aber
nichtsdestotrotz muss das Thema
Rüstungsindustrie natürlich morgen auch
eine wichtige Rolle spielen dass wir da
die Kapazitäten hochfahren müssen und
Herr Wüsten hat es ja gerade gesagt
jetzt wurde das Beispiel LNG Terminals
genannt wir können auch das Beispiel
Tesla nehmen und insofern wünsche ich
dem neuen Bundesverteidigungsminister an
dieser Stelle auch wirklich
Durchsetzungsfähigkeit nicht nur
gegenüber dem Kanzleramt sondern
gegenüber auch Kabinettskollegen wenn
wir von Beschleunigung
beschaffungsstraffung sprechen dann
betrifft das auch den
Wirtschaftsminister dann betrifft das
den Finanzminister die Minister die die
Außenministerin die müssen alle an einem
Strang ziehen und das muss endlich
ankommen und Teil der Zeitenwende werden
ein Traum oder möglich Frau Sauerbrei
ich glaube schon dass es noch möglich
ist also ich glaube die zeitenwände ist
ein Stück weiter als die vielleicht hier
eingangs auch gesagt haben also ich
glaube die was wichtig ist ist dass die
politisch psychologische zeitenwände ein
Stück weit geschafft ist und wir haben
die Umfragen zitiert und sie haben es
eher negativ ausgelegt aber wenn man
jetzt das den Deutschland Trend von
dieser Woche anschaut dann sind ja auch
40% der deutschen damit einverstanden
wie es jetzt ist es gibt viele Skeptiker
auch die sagen nicht unbedingt mehr
liefern aber es gibt auch wieder 20 und
ein bisschen Prozent die sagen ja unten
noch mehr liefern das heißt wir haben
die 40 die eigentlich zufrieden sind und
die 20 die sagen gerne noch mehr und das
ist ja auch wirklich was worauf man
aufbauen kann und wo man auch den
Konsens der Bevölkerung hat die
zeitenwände voranzutreiben und ich
glaube das ist in einer Demokratie
sicher das wichtigste wir machen hier
einen Punkt ich darf mich ganz herzlich
bedanken bei den Gästen heute Abend ein
herzliches Dankeschön auch nach Erfurt
zu Ihnen Herr Wüstner und wir sehen uns
in jedem Fall im nächsten Donnerstag
wieder gleiche Stelle solche Welle bei
Markus Lanz sitzt heute unter anderem
Daniel Günther Ministerpräsident von
Schleswig-Holstein und sie kommen gut
durch diese Nacht und schon bis nächste
Woche wenn Sie mögen vielen Dank
[Musik]